after more than a year two men finally
have their cars back from Dwayne's
Automotive they say it's a great feeling
good evening to you at 11 I'm Brian
Loftus I'm Denise Valdez we've been
telling you about the Henderson mechanic
that is being investigated now by the
DMV compliance board after refusing to
return cars to their owners Sasha Loftus
has been following this story for months
she joins us now live with an update
Denise and Brian both these men say they
can really breathe a sigh of relief
after a year of stress and financial
frustration while they still have quite
a few issues to work out with their cars
they say they're just happy to have them
back
call
it's finally the end of a long hard Road
for Gino darling and Aaron schlifka it
finally feels good to actually have it
in my possession both getting their cars
back from Dwayne's Automotive Wednesday
after dropping them off over a year ago
Aaron angino came to 8 news now for help
in November after they say the Henderson
mechanic went silent the Nevada DMV
compliance enforcement division opened
an investigation revoke Duane's business
license and were able to get a total of
five cars back to their rightful owners
there's several officers here on loan
vehicles
they attempted to start my vehicle it
starts smoking the men tell us their
cars were not fixed or even touched
during the entire year they were stuck
here so they'll still be dealing with
some Financial Fallout they had it taken
straight to another mechanic and they
said they don't there's not gonna be an
issue getting it fixed but both say
they're grateful to have their property
back I just want to thank the DMV and
channel 8 for helping out because
without you know without you guys
nothing whatever happened after so much
waiting and overwhelming frustration oh
it feels good
now as you heard Gino said he is taking
his car to another mechanic to get it
fixed now Aaron says he will cut his
losses and get rid of his car now the
DMV compliance enforcement division
encourages anyone else who's had issues
with Dwayne's Automotive here in
Henderson to contact them we have their
information on our website 8newsnow.com
reporting live tonight Sasha Loftus 8
News Now